To get squirrely,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Boom.
I gotta ask Donnie Vincent who made that
knife because people always ask me about
it.
It's awesome.
I could have used it on Saturday.
When is dfc the side that you guys were
on where you guys were in the crowd?
Did anybody jump toward you that way?
No.
The crowd mainly started.
It was because we were.
We had,
I'm pretty sure we had Irish right in
front of us and right in front of them
was some of Khabib's guys and Khabib's
guys were turning around just literally
throwing the fingers right to the Irish
guys the whole time.
So then once that happened it was like I
was lucky though.
I had A.
I had,
I had already and Whitney right there.
They were.
They were there to protect you?
Yeah,
they,
they were in full,
thrown down.
I was just,
I was one of the dumb people just kind
of looking around like the mushrooms
that everybody has there.
Any immediate danger?
No,
it A.
I mean,
obviously it seemed way worse over on
your side,
but I was more worried when they made us
leave because the further up you got in
the bleachers and once you got out into
the concession area and in the
bathrooms,
that's where stuff was going down.
Like just people from the crowd.
Um,
you know,
guys with Irish flags all obviously
we're getting trashed talk to them and
there was a big brawl right next to me
on the other side from where they were
sitting.
Right.
There was one just to our right.
I was looking at,
I believe it was the guy that jumped in
and the registered on convenience team
when they were trying to leave and
they're getting them out,
people in the crowd or like,
ah,
they start throwing shit at them first.
Like that's how the,
that's where the first shit was getting
thrown down and some other people know
that it was them.
We,
we all saw it.
She saw them as like,
that's the guy,
that's the guy right there right now.
It's like,
ah,
I don't know.
And he went and tried to do something
and I was doing but,
but
you know,
there's a price to be paid for all this
shit,
like all the,
all the drama and the trash talk and
that makes it so fun.
It also,
you know,
it has the potential for blown up in
your face ultimately.
Like couple people got punched.
But it was in an event where a bunch of
people got punched.
You know what I mean?
It's like way more than that.
It was awesome.
Yeah.
But you know what I'm saying,
it's like we,
we made it seem.
It seemed like it was way worse than it
really was because in any other
situation it would be way worse than it
really was.
Like if it was a rock concert and some
dudes just from,
you know,
like one band was the opening band and
then there was another band that was in
a bra with them and they were,
they were the main event and then the
fans of one band through down with the
fans of the other band of beat the shit
out of each other.
That would,
for whatever reason,
be way worse than when it's at a fight
because if it's at a fight,
it's just fighters.
Oh,
I saw this in St.
Cloud.
This was going on.
This insane clown posse guy tried to
drop kick Fred durst.
He wasn't even looking at them running
headstart and Mrs.
Look her.
I was like,
what?
And he just kept going.
I haven't seen drag that dude off.
I mean that is maybe the worst public
drop kick in the history of the world.
I think they meant he dropped when he
tried to kick while he tried.
That was a classic dropkick classic pro
wrestling dropkick.
But his problem is he threw it like a
pro wrestler would where you don't
really hit the guy.
You know what I mean?
Just kinda touched him.
And if Fred was playing along,
it would have been awesome.
We need a slow mo re.
Fred would have went flying and it would
have been,
you know,
fuck.
I think a lot of the lot of the,
uh,
the thing that's going through people's
minds too is when you're in a fight like
that,
there's a lot of people in the crowd
that can throw down.
It's not like,
you know,
you go to a well if you go to a hard,
a hard rock concert of any kind,
Clay Guido is going to be there
somewhere obviously,
but as long as you can avoid clay,
like your opportunity of finding a guy
that can really throw cuffs is going to
be way smaller than when you're at the
UFC and you look around.
It's hard not to see cauliflower ear.
So I mean someone who's in the crowd,
that's just a shit talker.
He knows.
If I just turn around and talk shit,
I can get wrapped up and be dead quick.
Yeah.
That's a very high number of people that
could fuck you up.
And one of those events,
it's probably like 30 percent,
30 percent of the people in the audience
actually know how to fight.
That's high.
I think that I think it'd be higher at a
UFC,
at least a basic.
I think it's about 30,
I'd say about 30 percent.
I feel like if you just like parcy
audience out,
like how many,
how many you guys ever been punched?
How many guys ever fuck somebody up.
How many guys actually trained?
How many guys know how to train and like
do it on a regular basis.
How many guys are in shape?
Like if shit went down,
how many guys could actually throw down
for a solid 37 days.
Yeah,
that's,
that's where you,
that's where I would shine.
I'm going to ride this out for two
minutes and then these,
these draft elk legs are getting ready
to frigging started dancing on some
April.
Let's beat the spazz out for a little
while and then,
then I'm good people,
you know,
when people were talking about,
um,
like uh,
connor in his conditioning for this
fight.
Like,
one of the things that I'm Cam Cam Hanes
said was like,
you know,
he needs to start running,
like go,
go run in the hills.
And my dad ain't going to help.
Like,
it would help some.
But the thing is,
when someone's wrestling you and they're
on top of you,
fucking you up like that,
you just get,
you're just getting drained.
It's like a vampire just sucking blood
out of you.
Yeah,
you're exhausted.
You carrying all their weight and you're
getting beat up and you're stressed and
you know you're trying to.
And you can't breathe well because the
person's weight is on top of you,
so you're not getting like real breaths
and you're constantly resisting their
weight.
And it's way easier for them that it is
for you.
It's way easy to stay on top than it is
to be on the bottom.
It's a disaster.
Well,
people that grew up wrestling,
you know,
you look at Miller Mendez,
Quita,
um,
those guys have experienced that
forever.
Like it's,
it's ingrained in them.
Most wrestlers don't lose like a classic
wrestling physique.
Even as adults,
they still look like they're,
like,
they were guys that were real athletic
at one time.
I remember one of the first things my
dad taught me,
you know,
when I was younger in school,
he's like,
uh,
you know,
I think it was after the first guy
wanted to fight me on the playground.
He's like,
you know,
if you don't know if the guy's good at
fighting,
don't worry about it unless he's a
wrestler.
He's like,
just if it's a wrestler,
try to back down.
He's like,
you don't know what to do.
Smart.
And Yeah,
it was classic this,
this weekend when I was watching that
fight.
I'm like,
okay,
here we go.
This is just a classic.
He's gonna,
you know,
connor had like 30 seconds,
they've started those rounds and then it
was just a mauling yeah.
Well John Cavanaugh,
who's connors trainer,
it will be here next.
He's going to be here at 11 and we'll
get a chance to talk to him and see what
the fuck he thinks and what happened.
And the bottom line is that guy is so
much better than him as a grappler.
So much better.
I mean he is on such a high level.
When I talked to Daniel Cormier,
Daniel called me.
He says that guy schools,
worldclass wrestlers in the gym just
throws people around.
Yeah.
Assassins probably one after another.
He's just mentioned this training.
Special talent.
He's been wrestling since he was a
little kid,
man.
I mean he really has this.
Have you ever seen the video of him
wrestling a bear?
No,
but I want you to ever sell.
I know,
but I want to fucking hilarious.
It's him wrestling a brown bear.
It's like a small brown bear,
like a Russian brown bear.
Like our version of a grizzly in Russia
and he's saying like coastal peninsula
bear like a peninsula.
Yeah.
Look,
look,
what is that?
That's him.
When he's a little kid.
Look at this.
I mean,
first of all,
who the fuck lets their kid there and
the bears bite them.
The Bear's bite and I'm looking as bare
as biting his clothes.
Bears a total cheater which prepared
them for connor this weekend.
Just kind of do a lot of cheating.
If I were to setup position would be
making a bet.
He gave a position because of the bite.
You see that he was on top and the bear
pit him and he let the get on top.
Now he's until it's over.
Look at this,
but it's not.
Bears are squirrely.
Man and bears have a really good guard.
He's laughing that at Sam as a little
boy.
Look at that.
Nineteen 97.
See,
we can't do that stuff in America.
I know.
That's why.
I mean,
imagine if Mendez got to go out and just
wrestle bears.
Look how little he is too.
I mean,
he's a little kid there,
man.
He looks like he's about eight years old
actually.
I think in the neighborhood I grew up
with the cheetahs.
They probably had one of these in the
garage.
A bearer.
Yeah.
Clay and Jason.
They were both kind of nuts.
Maybe they did wrestle some barriers.
What state was it was in Illinois.
So that were the Johnsburg yeah.
Problem.
This is awesome.
It's crazy.
You know what's interesting?
I've been,
um,
why does he bite back?
Didn't get that training that don't do
that because in the bear is really going
to get into looking at it.
We're just trying to bite his head.
He shifts just a little bear,
but his dad just like,
let them ride it out.
He said,
well,
the barrier is obviously being nice.
They're having fun and even though it's,
you know,
it's like when a dog's bite and you know
when you're playing with them and
they're done,
they're not trying to hurt you.
Look at that,
but also on a chain which is kind of
fucked up because the bear can't think.
I mean that beard,
that guard.
Very good.
Bears have a very good guard.
Look,
it says low.
I mean you.
Russians are fucking different.
Different breed and as things are hard
over there,
we try to make things softer and softer.
Over here we're given kids participation
trophies.
We don't want bullying there.
They're like,
we're bringing the grizzly into assembly
and we're going to wrestle grizzlies
today.
How old are you?
Eight.
And you have a restaurant,
grizzly yet.
What are you a pussy?
Yeah,
here we go.
A couple shots of vodka.
A grizzly bear or you're seeing a lot
of.
Very,
very tough guys come from that part of
the world and they're fighting in
combat.
Just guys.
Women.
Yeah.
Not just guys.
And in as much as we're talking about
wrestling,
he impressed me.
Stand up.
Oh yeah.
He cracked his right hand.
He,
he,
he stood up enough to just say,
you know,
I'm going to sit here and take a few and
I'm going to give a few.
But then he went to probably what his
game plan was,
I would assume.
Well you have to stand for a little
while because if he just shoots in who
get caught with a knee or caught with a
punch rushing in.
But uh,
he,
I mean he landed the bigger shot.
There was one big giant shot that was
landed in that fight and it was by hand.
He hit them with some pretty good front
kick to the body and some other things,
but didn't really get much off on the
feet.
Not like classic left Jabs that just
break people down and on the ground he
just got mall and it's one of those
things where you see that guy in the
beginning,
guys fight them off a little bit and
then as the fight.
Whereas on he just gets more and more
dominant.
They get more and more exhausted.
Really,
this fight just makes ally acquaint to
look like a god.
I mean,
that's the most impressive thing about
it.
Ally Quintin went five rounds with him,
stood toe to toe with him and you know,
gave him at least a struggle.
At least he gave him a bit of adversity,
you know,
managed to survive on the ground much
better than conor did.
Manage to get back up to his feet,
manage the stuff,
a bunch of take downs and on the feet
was a real threat,
you know,
I mean obviously Khabib didn't prepare
for ally Quinta.
He prepared for Connor,
but ally acquainted didn't even prepare
for five rounds.
The only prepared for three.
So there was so much to that fight.
What do you think will happen with
conner now?
I'm worried.
What happens with Khabib,
I hope they sit everybody down and they
go,
look.
Everybody's like,
all right,
come on,
you know.
So the guy who rushed into the cage and
punch connor in the face,
that guy,
that guy should be in the most trouble
because you know the guy just fought for
rounds,
got the fuck beaten out of them,
got choked.
I heard a lot of people.
There was a lot of silly non experts out
there saying that that wasn't a choke or
it wasn't a neck crank.
They don't know what the fuck they're
talking about that that is absolutely a
neck crank.
When someone gets their arm around your
head like that,
and then what they do is they grab it
like this and they pinched the elbow.
They put the forearm on his back like
this.
So as the arm is across the neck and
then they grip it like this and the
forearm goes into the back and pulling
like this.
You're pushing with your forum and
Yanking with your hand is a terrible
neck crank 'em they call dean lister
actually has a video on it.
It's.
He calls it the fulcrum choke and it's a
nasty choke.
So you know,
I thought he was going under the neck
here.
You could see it here,
dean lister,
who's a world champion,
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt and uh,
that's my friend Hans.
Hans Mellencamp behind them and watch
how he does it,
see how he's,
he's grabbing a hold of it.
And what he's gonna do is it's gonna
clamp his hands,
cle grips his hands and so it crushes is
doing this.
No,
no,
no.
You can go right over your face.
It can go over your neck and go over
your face and go over your fucking
cheekbones.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't even have to go under the
chin.
If it goes into the chin,
that's awesome,
but you see what's going on with his
forearm.
See how he's pull,
push,
pull arms.
Well,
you could do it some.
Some guys do it like this,
but I think this is probably the best
way to do it,
but as you're right here,
this part just digs that elbow.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Perfect example.
See,
he's pulling on it with his,
his right arm and then his left arm is
pushing down with his forum on Connor
Shoulder.
It is a nasty,
nasty neck crank and your head is
getting popped off and first of all,
that guy could squeeze the shit out of
you.
All you have to do,
there's a bunch of guys who could put
you to sleep like that.
Marcello Garcia is one.
He puts guys a cease put guys to sleep
without even getting under the chin.
He just gets your head.
Just get your head in there and
squeezes.
Eddie Bravo can do that too.
If it gets your head in there,
you don't even
have to.
It doesn't even have to be under the
chin.
He just really puts you to sleep with
your own fucking head.
Just wraps it around your head and
squeezes.
It's so tight that no blood is getting
to your brain.
Yeah,
so there's a lot of armchair
quarterbacks out there saying that that
was a neck crank your incorrect and have
dean list to do that shit to you and you
will know the pressure I had Jocko do
that to me.
My throat is still.
You don't want that.
No one will you rolling.
Which ACO?
That is a terrible idea.
Why did he,
why did he do that to you?
What did you do to him?
I don't know.
You were just trying to learn,
right?
Yeah,
I was trying to learn and I,
you know,
he said,
well who wants to roll?
And I just said me.
Yeah.
And he just,
he kind of just looked at me.
He's like,
well,
just try to do something,
but you're taking classes now,
right?
You taking 10th but I can.
Yeah.
We got one in Altoona,
Iowa.
So thanks to you and Eddie for hooking
me up with Damien.
What?
Shout out.
Shout out to Damien.
What's super important is drilling those
the most important thing in the
beginning.
It's sort of like,
uh,
there's,
there's parallels in archery for sure
because archery,
it's what's really important is your
technique.
Your technique is almost everything,
like doing everything correctly.
And that's the same thing with Jujitsu.
Same thing with Moitai,
taekwondo,
anything.
It's just technique and doing it over
and over again correctly until it's
ingrained in your system.
Yeah,
it's information overload for sure.
That's one of the hardest parts for me
is I'm so new at it.
Then I feel like my cognitive
functioning is not at a level to take
in.
There's so much going on and several
people have told me,
they're like,
they're.
There comes a point where all of a
sudden it just,
it,
it's something clicks and you start to
comprehend everything,
but until that moment happens,
it's,
you know,
you're going to struggle to remember
what you talked about last time or how
to do it exactly right.
But eventually there,
there comes a time when it clicks and it
starts to,
you know,
you do start to soak in stuff and I'm
definitely not to that point yet.
I mean,
just even some of the basic drills,
the one thing I do understand that they
were impressed by is just leverage on
joints,
you know,
because they were talking about some of
the different arm bars and stuff,
you know,
they were like,
well,
if the elbows like this,
and I said,
yeah,
that won't work.
The elbow has to be like this.
And I remember Damien looked at me like,
how do you know that?
And I'm like,
you know,
how many arms I've dissected off
animals.
If you have to knock four hooves off of
elk quarter to pack it out,
if you don't know where the joint is and
how to,
how to bend it and hit it just right to
crack that off.
That's a good point.
And you know,
hips,
shoulders,
even taking the head off.
I mean,
you know,
I think
that too,
but also your understanding of like the
proper positioning of your shoulders in
your elbow and everything in archery.
I think just an understanding of the
human body alone.
I think that that helps you
tremendously.
It's one of the reasons why people that
are really good at gymnastics.
Excel at Jujitsu,
people were really good at break dance.
I saw that.
Yeah.
Breakdancers excel.
Um,
Yoga,
a lot of yoga people,
they get really good at yoga.
They can excel at Jujitsu to.
It's just you,
you have a,
just an understanding of what the way
your body moves in my mind,
both mind body connection,
like being able to really have a mind
muscle connection.
And some people don't understand that.
You tell them to do a pull up and you're
like,
you really want to use lattes?
And they're like,
well,
what's that?
Yeah.
They don't know.
They have no idea.
Yeah.
They just pull in.
And some people when they,
when they pull a boat for the first
time,
even big guys,
they struggle pulling a boat because
they're not their techniques.
Poor.
So they're,
you know,
they're lifting apart or pulling all
with bicep down and it's like,
man,
can you just lift up and goes straight
back with,
you know,
just certain muscles of the back.
And when they see it they're like,
how do you do that?
And it's just understanding of leverage
in muscle and then you know,
once they understand that flow it gets
really easy.
But until that it looks like they're
trying to literally do a Max rep gets
that too.
But it's also,
you probably have done it a million
times so your arms are so conditioned to
do that.
It's such a natural movement.
Possibly.
Most.
Probably several million.
Yeah.
I would say probably several.
Well here's a perfect example of use.
Most people,
even if they have like a strong left
arm,
like if I go back,
flex your arm,
you see a good left Bicep,
you know you look got good shoulders and
you left hand.
And then I bring you to a heavy bag and
I say throw a left hook.
Most people's left hooks are fucking dog
shit.
Just straight up talk shit.
Hit somebody to throw out there.
Like it just,
it just doesn't work.
It doesn't like someone throw a baseball
lefthanded.
It just looks terrible.
It's even worse.
I think you might be able to throw
because the concept of throwing seems
normal.
But the concept of digging in with your
toes and turning your body into the hook
and then if you do it and you just do it
slowly,
just bang and hit a bag.
They're like,
how are you doing that?
And he just like,
you just get used to it.
For the [inaudible] when I was,
when I was striking all the time,
my left bicep was quite a bit larger
than my right one.
My left arm was actually stronger than
my right because you're always jabbing,
you always jabbing,
jabbing and hooking and you throwing
less right hands and you are left hands.
And so my left side was bigger,
like my left arm.
I had a bit like I could see it.
Like if I flex the two of them together,
my left bicep look larger and that's a
normal thing with boxers.
They're there.
If you,
if you're not a person switch the
stances and you yourself in an orthodox
stance with your left leg forward,
you will,
you'll have a stronger lefthand.
Like I would be able to open things
better with my left hand and my right
hand.
Not Weird.
Well,
I mean,
yeah,
you're in your,
you're turning so much too,
so I mean I guess when you're snapping
back you're kind of soup and aiding the.
When you come back think it's just the
use,
just the sheer number,
like the.
If you looked at like a really good box
or left hand versus right hand,
you might throw two to one,
maybe three to one,
three,
11 slash three to three to one.
Yeah.
If you're doing it right,
you know you're supposed to be jabbing
more than you are just throwing
haymakers.
Well one of my,
one of the highlights of the fight there
were several Ferguson's match was
amazing.
Ferguson's incredible.
I mean incredible too.
That guy had catastrophic knee surgery,
like his knee was so blown out.
They were,
they were not sure if he was going to be
able to fight again.
They were like,
I don't know what's gonna happen here
because he had ripped his tendon
completely off the bone.
The scar on his leg is enormous.
His scars like 12 inches long,
that fucking massive scar.
So they had to open him up like a fish
and then they have to get in there and
they have to bolt down that ligament to
the,
to the bone.
Were they able to use the same one back
down?
Yeah.
I mean he had surgery almost immediately
after the injury.
He didn't have to have a cadaver or
anything like that and the way they do.
Uh,
I don't,
I honestly don't know exactly what was
involved.
But look at that knee.
Cut The fucking name,
man.
That's incredible.
That's,
I mean,
that is incredible.
And then six months later he's not just
healed up.
He's got Anthony Pettis kicking that
leg.
Yeah.
We're very concerned in the beginning of
the fight,
it looked like he got hurt on that leg
because pedes hit that leg twice really
hard and it looked like he was wobbly a
little bit on that leg was going to say
he survived a catastrophic flurry.
Yeah,
I mean that is caught him.
Yeah.
He came back big time because it didn't
look good.
There were several fighters that dug
really deep that we're in trouble and
came back for some awesome.
Come back about Derrick Lewis.
He's the best.
He's my official favorite now.
I love that.
That fucking post fight interviews.
My favorite posts for sure.
I go,
Derek,
why'd you take your shorts off?
I'm a balls was hot.
I love that.
I got a phone call before to fight.
Donald trump called me and said I got
knocked this Russia motherfucker out and
make get everybody look bad.
When I was putting shit,
I was in the crowd and I'm like.
I looked at Sharon,
say his balls were.
She's like,
yeah.
She goes,
I think he did.
Yeah,
he put the crowd.
I don't think appreciated it as much as
the people back home.
It was hard to hear people back home.
They got it straight from his mic into
their TV.
They got the full version of it.
Yeah.
It was muffled.
Pretty hardcore,
but so classic.
He so funny man.
And,
and what a fucking punch her.
Holy Shit.
Can that guy crack?
Because he was down as down as you can
get.
I mean,
he's basically three rounds in the cam,
three rounds in the hole and 30 seconds
to go.
We were saying that we were saying it in
the commentary that he still has the
kind of power where one shot could win
the fight and people like,
yeah,
yeah.
But as you're going to live,
that's what's hard about being live at
the fight.
You,
um,
you don't really get the commentary and
your guys's commentary so good when
you're watching on paper view,
it's dissecting so many things that you
aren't,
you know,
unless you're a very seasoned at
watching mma,
you don't appreciate a lot of that
stuff.
And when you're watching with no one's
opinion,
you're kind of just watching and waiting
for something like that to happen where
there's a lot of times you guys are
calling that you're seeing some of that
stuff that needs to happen or should
happen.
And they used to have this thing that
you could get.
I don't think they have it anymore.
It was like a little FM radio.
Did you see it at the scene?
It in a while?
No,
I don't think they have it anymore,
but it used to be a little thing that
you would,
you would buy at the gift shop,
so like a little in a doubled as an FM
radio,
so if you used it like it would still
would work somewhere else as a radio,
but when you keep it on a certain
frequency,
they would broadcast the commentary so
you would get the commentary and you can
keep it in your ear while the fight was
going on.
Yeah,
that is one of the things that that's
missing just a little bit.
Yeah,
but it's just there's something about
being in the building.
Especially that one.
Yeah,
there was just electricity,
like Sha radiating from person to person
in the crowd.
It was electric.
Yeah.
That was probably the biggest UFC of all
time.
I mean it has to be one of them,
you know,
they don't know.
I won't know for another day or so,
but I think it's the most important
fight of all time because connor being
such a huge superstar and then being out
of mma for two solid years and then
Khabib just being so dominant 26 and.
Oh,
and then there was also like the
controversy of like how he won the
title.
You know,
he won the title last minute.
He was supposed to be fighting Tony
Ferguson.
Tony gets injured,
ally Quinta steps up and it's further
title and everyone is like,
what?
How is that for the title?
Yeah.
You know,
the whole thing was just very,
very weird.
If there's not a,
a rematch which you would think numbers
wise,
there has to be.
I don't think so.
I wouldn't think there'd be a rematch.
Not for a long time.
Well,
what's awesome is if there isn't and
counter the counter politics or out of
that weight class now some of the fights
we'd get to see like I'd love to see him
in Ferguson would be bringing fight.
That's
a fight 100 percent now after ferguson
dominated pedis like that.
And then also overcame that big shot
where he got hurt.
Yeah,
I don't.
I don't want to see mcgregor versus can
be begin.
I don't think he was going to be any
different.
There's so many more that would just be
awesome.
I would like to see it in the future.
I mean,
but connor would have to do something to
show that he,
first of all,
there is absolutely a factor in that he
had not been fighting for two years.
Yeah.
One boxing match in two years is just
not good enough for MMA.
Especially with wrestling.
Just not good enough.
And then I think he would have to like
really,
really concentrate on is wrestling and
even that.
Even that.
I mean,
how much better can you get,
dude?
That guy was wrestling a bear as a kid.
I mean,
he's so much better.
Yeah.
He's going to have to go back in time
and rethink this.
I mean,
Khabib might just have his number for
life,
you know,
that's what [inaudible] said.
You know,
I was talking for me after the fight,
he said,
he was like,
listen to me.
He's never going to beat him.
Never.
I go,
you don't think you can ever get to the
point where he'd get his take down
defense up enough.
He's like,
it'll never happen.
He's never going to get there.
It's too far away.
He's got to get a just a clean one shot
that just ends up.
That would be it.
It's like that in my field too.
I mean I stay.
I guess I stay honed,
but I'm not like razor sharp in my
field.
Just so like you mean like target
archery?
Like if you're going to compete.
Yeah.
People all the time say,
why don't you,
why don't you compete in it?
Can I shoot better than most people at
this point?
Yeah,
I can answer that without question.
Can I shoot at a,
at a word?
Like could I have beat myself when I was
shooting on the teams?
No Way.
Like that was a different person and
when I stepped away for,
for two or three years,
even though I contemplated coming back,
I'm like,
this commitment is going to take a year,
two years of really fine tuning because
I mean at those levels,
people don't miss,
you know,
so missing one or two still means it's a
weekend,
it's still a tournament,
like you have to be flawless and if
you're not flawless then all you're
doing is donating money.
And when you compete in those
tournaments with the distance,
it depended.
There were several different formats,
um,
anywhere from 18 meters which you were
shooting at something the size of a dime
in most of those,
you know,
like a 600 round you would need to be,
you know.
Then I was shooting like,
you know,
upper five nineties,
I'm at something the size of time
explaining what that means.
So like to hit that,
hit that exercise of a dime as a 10.
So you would have to,
you know,
literally says she times,
yeah,
out of arrows in,
in like in tournament play,
you would have to hit that dime,
you know,
57 times.
Um,
and then when we went out to the longer
distances up to 90 meters,
I mean,
you have to be shooting something a
little bit larger than the end of that
Coffee Cup.
You know,
you'd have to,
you'd have to be deadly accurate with
that thing.
I mean,
you're going to have to be in,
in the high 90 percentile of being able
to hit that
and you also get used to the
competition.
You get sharper because your minds in
that place that all the time,
that's the hardest part.
Even if you're on the game,
which there's been times like this past
summer,
um,
I had a event that I did for um,
a Cabela's experience where some of the
Kybella is black signature card members
kind of,
I guess bought an experience.
And I did some training at the Easton
Center with them.
And then we went and shot the total
archery challenge in,
in Utah.
And we talked,
I talked through the technicalities of
what you would do on each shot,
what the total archery challenges for
total archery challenge is a tournament
that order's not even a tournament.
It's more of a fun event where they set,
it's in snowbird and they set archery
targets like in real hunting situations,
but with very,
very technical shots,
extreme angles,
longer distances.
He got cross winds and canyons and
snowbird from people don't know is a ski
course.
What does that actually have the video
and uh,
yeah,
it's just very technical because
you're the footings poor.
Yeah.
This is a,
this is the total archery challenge.
So it's really interesting because it's
in the summertime,
but it's at a ski place,
a ski range,
what would you call it?
A Ski,
what'd you call it?
Yes,
of course.
No,
it's a,
it's a ski lodge.
Yeah.
But what is,
what is where the,
where the flips.
It's literally a resort.
Yeah.
Snowbird.
So you take the ski lifts up to where
these things are.
And uh,
these targets are all set up.
There were all these foam deer and foam,
sheep and all these different game
animals and they're at extreme distances
and weird angles.
You take
the,
uh,
take the tram all the way to the top of
the mountain and then you literally
shoot down.
I think it was about six miles for us to
get down.
I think our total walk one day was about
six miles.
Um,
but I shot it with this group and taught
them the technicalities of it.
And because of that I really wanted to
be prepared.
I knew that there was going to be people
there watching.
I knew that because I stepped into an
actual event where there were a few
thousand archers there.
I knew that there was going to be a lot
of people watching me because I haven't
gone out into that realm in a while.
It would be no different than a false
and you know,
you were out of mma for awhile and then
went in there,
you know,
there's going to be eyes on you.
So I just wanted to be on my game,
um,
or as best as I could be.
So I've set a goal,
I'm trying to think what it was.
I think I set a goal of like,
I think it was around 10,000
arrows I wanted to shoot prior to that.
I'm so over a course of just a few
months.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think the one day I shot round $500 a
day.
A tie.
I think a timelapse one of those,
I don't know if you remember that.
Um,
but once you go there,
even if you're totally on your game,
if you have to shoot with other guys
that are elite level athletes,
there's still a lot that goes into it.
I mean that.
And especially if you're shooting for
score,
you're shooting for money.
Those pressure factors,
if you're not acclimated to them,
those aren't things that you can just
step back into.
When I was my best as a competitor,
I always like,
my practice was almost at tournaments.
Every weekend it was 40 something events
a year.
You know,
every three days you're at a tournament
in the heat of the moment with the best
five or six people in the world and then
you go home for a few days to repack you
retune and then you're right back in the
grind again,
somebody's got stripped of a title
because they tested positive for thc and
Beta blockers.
This is real recent,
right?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
When I competed.
Um,
so I mean,
yeah,
you a year depending on what level
you're at.
There was because I shot with the U,
s team,
certain tournament's didn't have doping
and then.
But when you shot anything that was on a
world level you did.
So I was always in a doping pool,
so it was no different than like when I
was,
I was,
uh,
with Chad Mendez at a Turkey hunt and he
made a testing pool.
Yeah.
So they would test your blood or your
urine.
What would the test?
Either one.
Yeah.
And you'd be on call,
you'd have to live with Beta blockers.
What does that,
what do they do you ever told that?
Know that it's supposed to kill alarms,
right?
I would think it blocks adrenaline,
The ability for your brain to dump
adrenaline.
So yeah,
the,
the number one thing in archery or any
type of finesse sport is,
you know,
low heart rate keeping your heart rate
down because that's obviously keeping,
you know,
keeping your mind in the game.
Um,
and stability.
Very minimal movements.
So yeah,
there's,
um,
I remember I had a coach a long time
ago,
he talked about um,
alcohol and how alcohol could help
shooter because we,
we were talking about a guy that had
done well at tournament several times
and I said,
yeah,
he always does.
And he said,
yeah,
he's always,
he's always drunk.
And I'm like,
what do you mean?
And he said,
well,
he goes,
if you play alcohol the right way and
you're like,
not sloppy drunk,
but you're,
he goes,
yeah,
he just stays in his zone.
And he just kinda sitting there drinking
the whole time.
And that was like prior to where they
were testing for alcohol.
So he actually made us,
uh,
he said,
all right,
well let's see how you,
how you do if you shoot when you have a
buzz going.
So,
you know,
we,
we drank and shot and uh,
you know,
don't try this at home kids,
it wasn't an archery range where they
have to buy insurance or whatever.
But uh,
yeah,
and it,
you know,
that was part of it because at the time
this was in the mid nineties,
another archer that had won a bunch of
titles also tested positive for Beta
blockers and had some title stripped.
But then for the longest time that was
one of my complaints was once I was
shooting,
I'm at a level with,
with the teams and we had to go through
testing or be like if,
for example,
at an event when I met old,
if you're in the top three,
immediately you get tested.
I mean,
so that's how it is.
So you know,
everyone there is level,
they're all level,
but then you go to other events.
Like for example,
some of the biggest money events were
the three d shoots and that was a big
reason why I left those sheets because
at those tournaments there was no
testing,
there was no testing,
there was clearly guys there that were
shooting that we're kind of just out of
it.
There could be $50,000
on the line and there was just no,
not a sweat cracked because there were
some of that stuff.
Obviously it is a performance enhancer
because of the fact they're not having
to deal with adrenaline spikes and
accelerated heart rate for people don't
know what we're talking about.
Three d shoots are a type of tournament
where they have those,
a realistic looking targets.
So foam elks or a foam bear and they
have,
you know,
areas that you're supposed to hit.
Yeah.
And,
and um,
the other thing was I didn't like the
fact that I'm at that time when you
scored,
it was just based off if there's four
guys in the group,
whatever the majority voted,
that's how it's scored.
And when there's a lot of money online.
So like say you shot and I shot Jamie
shop and Sharon shot,
we'd walk up and you know,
it's their phone ring so the era could
look like it's in,
it could look like it's out,
but it's not a clear line and we would
just,
if me,
you and Jamie said that's out.
Then even if Sharon's was close,
it'd be out.
Um,
so I was in some groups where things got
a little shady.
People are wanting to make money and it
got a parent that it wasn't,
there wasn't a judge.
They're calling every score,
which on a world level there's judges
there.
So if you guys were all competing
against each other,
you would call for each other.
I've seen groups where they did.
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I've seen groups where they.
Do you ever tried their Beta blocker?
No.
I want to know what that's like.
I'd like to do something nerve wracking,
try a Beta blocker and then do something
fucking really.
Nerve wracking can mean any throw you
out of
please.
I think you would like it whether I'd
like it or not.
It's not happening.
Well,
not interested.
It doesn't get much sketchier than that
roller coaster we're on.
Yesterday we did the rollercoaster at
New York,
oof,
sketch city.
That thing felt like it was tied
together with Bubblegum floss.
It feels so uncomfortable.
You're like,
wait a minute.
This is just way it's old.
It's outside.
Everything is outside.
You're flying around the casino itself
like and the whole thing just feels like
it shouldn't be there.
Yeah.
I think there's several things there
that are a little outdated.
Yeah.
I was in the,
I was,
I was one row behind you guys and uh,
I was next to this kid who had never
ridden a rollercoaster and he was
terrified.
He was terrified and I thought,
have I just not been on one of these
long for that long to where this feels
like it could possibly shake off and we
could launch on like what was the last
time a rollercoaster did break loose?
Like when was the last side of someone
or something?
Last year,
I believe it happened.
Something happened last year.
Don't show him one of those carnivals.
Roll into town.
Yeah,
that's on you.
If you get on one of those fucking
things.
I was at one a couple of years back and
I took a picture of it for instagram
because there was a.
This one of those whirlwind things.
Oh,
rollercoaster derails to writers.
Fall 30 feet to the ground and Daytona
beach.
Oh,
don't show me this either.
That's just afterwards.
Oh,
that's it.
Hanging.
Got the live video.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Daytona beach.
But that's Florida.
See anything that's fucked up could
happen in Florida.
I guarantee that guy was fixing that on
oxycontin.
It's probably got a python in his
pocket.
Fucking assholes.
They need one of those in the buckies.
Do they have a rollercoaster in a
buckies yet?
No.
They don't need one.
Just Texas.
Texas is not known for roller coasters.
That a little wiser than that.
I bet you could wrestle grizzly bears in
Texas though.
Like if someone wanted to train.
Oh yeah.
You could probably shoot them to do
whatever you want.
Yeah.
We could do a brown bear wrestling
training camp.
It's an exotic.
That's the whole thing about Texas,
like if thing,
if it's an exotic animal,
meaning it's not indigenous,
not native,
you can kind of do whatever the fuck you
want to.
It is crazy.
Text is a fascinating place.
It's one of the weird states that almost
all the land is private.
That's,
that's a rare thing.
Like there's a public land system in
this country with the bureau of land
management and all the different
national parks.
There's like none of that in Texas.
You know,
Texas is mostly just private ranches.
That's weird.
Right?
It's very weird.
It's very weird that there's been roads
I've been down where you're just driving
and for miles and miles and miles is
nothing but high fence.
It's like people's private ranch is just
like gated in.
Yeah.
You know,
it's strange because they have these
ranches that they seem like wilderness
because the ranch will be like 10,000
acres.
Right.
But if it's 10,000
acres,
it's fenced in and party.
He goes,
well,
hey man,
the whole country's fed fenced in.
He gets to the ocean.
He can't go any further.
That shit's Kinda like a third that
excuse,
but there you guys how I look at it,
you go far enough north,
you hit the ice,
he hit the glaciers.
Yeah.
Where you going?
But there's something about that kind of
experience.
Like that's one of the weirdest things
about Texas is that they have these
enormous fenced in properties where they
have all these African animals running
around,
like Neil guy and Elan's and you name
it.
Yeah.
And they're,
they're zebra.
More of those animals running around in
Texas than they do in the wild of their
countries.
Like oryx,
oryx.
They're like,
they're threatened in other parts of the
world.
Right.
They've got a ton of them down there,
Texas.
They got up fuck load and black books.
Yeah,
lots of stuff.
Yeah.
They have lots of stuff access the same
way,
but.
So how do you feel about that?
Like if you,
if the place is like this is like a
philosophical argument,
right?
If it's 10,000
acres and it's fenced in,
that's far greater than their natural
range,
right?
Yeah.
Normally wouldn't wander any further
than that.
It's an ongoing debate.
I mean,
it is Squirrelly,
right?
Yeah,
it's squirly.
Yeah.
There's um,
because even with like animals that
they,
you know,
where they want to score and then put
into the record books,
you know,
to keep track of scores.
So,
you know,
there are certain score scoring clubs
that don't recognize anything with a
high fence,
but then at the same time there's
members within those organizations that
are like,
well,
wait a minute,
you know,
if,
uh,
ranches 15,000
acres that's,
you know,
they kind of have this same argument.
And they said,
well,
is that.
And it's like,
well,
yeah,
I mean if,
if there is.
And as a hunter,
it's one of the things that um,
there's kind of a continual debate.
Some hunters absolutely refused to hunt
anything that has any sort of
containment.
Other people have their kind of,
their,
you know,
they have their own threshold of,
well if it's 5,000
or more than I'm kind of okay with it.
It's hard.
I mean,
it's no different than,
you know,
some people in the hunting community.
Some people only want to hunt animals
that are on public land.
And then some people like to hunt areas
where it's,
you know,
it's managed properties,
it's privately owned properties that
have really good management and you
know,
that,
you know,
you're shooting,
a certain age limit,
you're kind of calling out,
you know,
the older animals maybe that aren't
breeding anymore.
Um,
so yeah,
there's,
there,
there's continual differences of what
people feel like they want to accept.
Some people want to be able to.
Some people just like hunting,
like nugent.
He just loves hunting his ranch.
Right?
I mean he unsat thing.
I think he also has,
he's has a problem moving around.
Well he doesn't mean he can't really go
elk hunting like where it goes hiking
into the mountains eight,
10 hours a day.
He can't legitimately loves hunting
Texas ranches.
Like he legitimately tree stands.
I mean I think he's limited to that.
Like he has two bad knees,
like really bad,
like [inaudible].
He's got artificial knees.
He said some serious surgeries.
We've got friends that loved to hunt.
I'm like exotic ranches.
Yeah.
Well I can see.
I could see the argument both ways.
Like if you're a meat eater and you want
to get meat from a free range cattle
ranch,
you know you only want grass fed,
grass finished beef free range that
roams around.
Like there's a lot of people that feel
that way.
Yep.
Well,
what is why you're hunting?
Are you hunting because you,
you want meat?
Are you hunting because you want to kill
your on meat?
Are you hunting because you want to eat
wild game or you're hunting because it's
fun or you're hunting for all the
reasons all the above and if it's,
if it's an all of the above,
some people feel like the only kind of
hunting they want to do is backpacking.
Public land.
Yep.
Go into the wilderness and they don't
want to have anything to do with raising
those animals,
helping those animals.
They want those animals be straight up
wild,
you know,
and they feel like that is the most
ethical way.
There's a lot of weird debates about
public land to.
Here's one that really gets me is a lot
of people that are really into public
land and public land is super important
to them.
They want,
they only want to hunt public land,
but they have secret spots on public
land.
They don't want anybody to know about
them and if you tell someone about their
spot on public land,
they'll get mad at you.
Like if you take someone to a spot,
I've heard Rinella talk about this on
the show,
like he's the big public land guy,
but he'll talk on his show about what a
betrayal it is.
If you tell a person about a spot and
they tell someone else about that spot
or they go to that spot without you
like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Is this public land or is it not?
And if it's not,
if it is public land,
if you're telling someone about a spot,
you're telling me that this public land
spot you don't want them going to
without you.
Not unless they find it on their own.
Dad Is fucking ridiculous.
Right?
That's ridiculous.
That's like spot.
You have a private spot on public land,
so you're a public land guy until it
infringes on your own privacy,
like you figured out a way to have a
private spot on public land and if you
share this private spot with someone
else,
they're not allowed to go there without
you.
Fuck you.
That's crazy dude.
That's the number one rule in fishing to
someone takes or it's not.
Yeah,
but if someone takes you to a sweet
little spot where they just rip lips
constantly on,
on a lake and then next thing you know
they go out there on the weekend and
you're sitting there in your boat with a
bunch of buddies that stupid.
This is going to get mad and be like,
Bro,
I took you to my spot.
Well,
they're assholes.
Stupid.
I don't think so.
You think they should not go there?
I think there's.
Do you think they own that spot?
It's fucking child.
They don't own it.
Let's,
let's talk about like lake superior.
Okay.
We got a giant ass lake and someone has
a spot where all the lake trout live.
A little reef.
Yeah,
where everything's chill and tell me
about that spot and then you go back
there six months later and I'm at that
spot.
You're going to be mad at me.
No,
probably not.
Not Me,
but what if it's a guy that you don't
know as well?
If I went back and you had a whole bunch
of guys there,
it'd be like,
dude should have saved this spot for
this ridiculous.
It's a fucking public lane.
Not taking you in any of my spa did not
see.
This is the thing,
this,
these people that say they want
everything to be public.
That's not public.
It's not public.
If you don't want other people going
back there.
I see the argument though,
because he put in the work to find a
good place that took work within public
land and you better not tell people
about it or they're going to go back.
Yeah,
that's will.
That's where you go wrong.
Yeah.
If you find it,
you gotta just you gotta just keep it
quiet.
That's so corny.
That's so ridiculous.
Like,
do you want that spot to yourself?
You want that spot to be private in a
way.
Yeah,
you do.
You're making a private area and public
land.
That's what you're doing.
Yep.
I think that's preposterous.
Well,
could you imagine if you say you were
going to cotton,
you left camp an hour and a half before
daylight and you pack all the way out
there and there's someone sitting on
your glass and rock in that basin.
It's not yours,
but you would still say,
I should've never told this guy that was
here.
All right.
Someone got there first.
No one's ever tell you about their
spouses spot.
That's been the same way for hundreds of
thousands a year.
It has way it has,
but someone found it put in the work to
find it.
This is small minded thinking,
man,
this is small minded thinking.
I know.
Sorry,
but this is a common way of thinking.
I would say.
I'd say there's people that don't think
that way,
but there are certainly people that are.
I would have to side with with grinnell
on that.
Really?
Yeah.
So you think.
So let me ask you this.
So if you,
if someone takes you to a place and it's
this really good meal deer spot and you
gotta you hike in seven miles and this
is beautiful base in and you go there
and just just to always deer there,
you don't go there without that person's
permission would tell.
I would say,
are you going to be there?
And if he said no and I'd say,
can I go,
I wouldn't take that would be carried on
national forest land.
Can I go to public land?
Can I go to this spot?
You don't fucking own even a little bit
out of respect for that guy that found
it,
found it.
Yeah.
Just walked.
He walked on the dirt,
found what?
A tree.
Those are more true.
This is crazy.
Martin rocked.
I stand on this top to cliff is cliff.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
I mean you can take it to a point,
but craze I still think it's code is a
weird code.
The other argument though too,
is just from a hunting situation,
Jamie is a person who doesn't hunt it
all.
I mean,
I,
I've heard it so I understand like it's
not a new concept to me,
but I'm trying to compare it to
something else.
Like if it was a pickup basketball hoop,
I found somewhere not built until
somebody to go to that playground
because it's my hoop and I show up at
people or they're playing a public
playground.
Fine.
Another hoop to play on.
Well,
you don't play basketball.
That seems ridiculous,
but I'm just trying to think that you,
like you have a specialty in today's Day
and age because today people use like
onyx maps and they use google earth and
you could find these beautiful spots and
you just go out to them.
Like if you find a beautiful spot on
google earth and you go out to it and
you go,
hey man,
this is a spot I found don't golder to
merge.
But bottom public wind seems ridiculous.
Yeah,
it does.
It does.
But there,
I think there's a legitimate code to it.
It seems ridiculous,
but it seems understandable that someone
will be upset if they're looking forward
to going to a place and they told you
about it a year ago and they go to that
place.
They hike him,
takes him nine miles when you were
there.
Yeah.
Tough Shit.
Go.
Another nine should have got there
earlier.
You procrastinate and Motherfucker,
I'm taking you with me when we're going
into someone's spot.
I'll let you.
No one owns any spots.
See,
that's what's so weird about it.
To me.
It's,
it's there.
There definitely is.
There definitely is a line.
I mean,
I see your argument 100 percent and I
know it,
you know,
at some point it,
it,
it could definitely get childish or out
of hand.
I mean obviously there's a ton of a ton
of stuff,
but out of courtesy.
Yeah.
I mean if anytime you showed me
something cool,
if you're like,
hey,
I got this cool thing is what I do,
you know,
it's kind of private.
Take my family there,
whatever.
I'd like.
Yeah,
I respect
that,
but it's not private.
That's what's weird.
What's weird is the whole water's not
either public land,
but fishermen would be the same.
Right?
Captain still close captains.
It is.
The thing about public land is that it's
supposed to be everyone's.
So if you find a really good area in
public land that's supposed to be
available for everyone.
Yeah.
It does not.
What everybody wants what everybody
wants.
That's one of the things about people
not wanting new people to get into
hunting.
Like I've heard this argument before,
like you shouldn't be telling people to
get into hunting because it's already
tough.
A tough enough out there on public land
has already so many people hunting on
public land.
If more people get into hunting,
who's going to be more pressure?
Like what?
And yeah,
that's,
that's not me.
I'm definitely looking to get more
people in for sure.
Right?
Because you're thinking they didn't know
about your spots.
I'll find a new spot.
That's a good attitude.
One of the,
um,
one of the questions or I guess
arguments too is,
you know,
I don't understand that when people,
they don't have any tolerance for like
hunting private land,
so to speak,
or they don't have tolerance for,
you know,
I don't mind people that hunt exotic
ranches or hunted high fence.
That's just not,
that's like not what I personally like,
but I also understand that people do.
But I,
I also don't like it when people are
like super negative to that,
but yet they'll have like a bull in a
pen or they'll have chickens in a cage
or they'll have a goat in there like
raising and raising and go to slaughter.
I Dunno,
is it that is because it shows us a
different scale.
No,
but it's not because it shows that
there's a difference.
Hang in the pursuit of a wild animal.
There's a different thing to that.
Like,
like here's the thing,
say if you,
there's a ranch and the ranch is 5,000
acres,
which is big but not the biggest.
And on that 5,000
Acre ranch,
someone shoots a giant buck like a huge
two for 240 inch mule deer,
epic deer and people are like wow,
but it's a private ranch and you kind of
know that there wasn't a lot of pressure
there so they probably knew where this
deer was and people that worked on this
ranch told people about this deer and
they kind of kept their eye on it and
they knew where to go to find them.
Versus you getting your truck driving
four hours outside of Reno in Nevada,
getting out into the mountains by
yourself.
You're like setting up camp by yourself,
spending three or four days just
scouting,
just earning your spot,
finding your styles out there,
finding your spot.
But it's more difficult as the point.
So like if someone accomplishes that,
you look at it differently than someone
who's shot something in a high ranch in
Texas,
it's just a different thing.
Yeah.
But what I know
what I'm saying is like hunters versus
non hunters,
people that are non hunting that really
looked down on like what
we're talking about is hires.
But yet they'll raise a goat to
slaughter in attending that.
It's some sort of pursuit man versus.
And See,
the thing about the hunting thing is
you're,
you're looking at it like it's a
difficult pursuit.
Like you're out there trying to outwit
this animal.
For me.
Yeah,
that's what I like about it.
But if you're in a 400 acre fenced in
property with a bunch of exotics running
around,
you're sitting in a tree stand is a pile
of corn down there and you're waiting
for an animal to walk over to that
corner and you whack it.
That is very different than say what you
did this year in Alberta when you were
telling me that you were hiking hundreds
of.
I mean,
how,
how many days did you guys go?
I think we went nine.
Did 100 miles.
Yeah.
So you hiked a hundred miles in the
wilderness for nine days?
No elk and never got.
Never got one.
Yeah.
That is very different.
Right?
So.
Oh yeah.
That's real hunting in comparison to
someone who's sitting over a pile of
corn fenced in ranch.
Yeah,
that's,
that's why I think people have a problem
with it,
the,
that anybody would compare what you did
to that and then there's like the
intermediary,
which is like a really nice ranch that's
not high fence,
but it's a private ranch like the place
we went to in Utah that is private.
Not everybody can go there,
but those are just wild animals roaming
around and uh,
yeah.
And opportunities high.
Yes.
More opportunity,
but no,
nothing fenced in.
Nothing's keeping the animals there and
they,
those animals had been there for
thousands of years.
It's just what they do.
You just have the opportunity to hunt a
wild animal on a piece of property where
there's not going to be a lot of people
there.
Yup.
Yeah,
it's my preference.
I like doing,
I really liked the balance of having
really tough aunts,
especially because I knew my,
you know,
my Utah Hunt wouldn't quite be the same.
That was kind of a very different
experience for me.
I haven't ever had an opportunity like
that,
so that was quite a,
quite a difference for me.
Whereas I'm between the other states
that I hunted,
I think I did.
I think I was right at just over 200
miles before,
uh,
before we got our first bull,
you know,
between there and then hunting some,
uh,
some private land,
but also some public land in Montana
before finally getting that first elk.
Can you talk about what happened with
Montana?
With the bear?
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
I can talk about it.
They actually text me back and ruled
back that it was not a grizzly.
What's.
Yeah,
they say it's A.
I'm a colored black bear.
Do you think that's true?
Um,
yeah,
it's possible.
I was going to pull up the pictures.
It's a black bear.
Yeah.
It thought it was a grizzly.
Yup.
We shot,
uh,
actually,
um,
our,
our mutual friend Andy Stumpf,
Shahada Bull on nine slash 11,
which was,
which was pretty,
um,
pretty cool for him to have an
experience like that.
And it took us,
um,
I forget how far out we were,
just several,
several miles from camp and we,
it took us two trips to pack this bull
out.
And,
uh,
the first pack out that we did,
I think we finally got back to camp,
I don't know,
somewhere around midnight or something.
So the next morning we went back at
firstlight,
took us a while to pack back in there.
And when we got there,
um,
half of the carcass,
I had already pulled everything apart.
We had everything gained bags,
everything was strung up in trees,
but the actual cavity was half buried.
And as we were approaching I seen
something kind of running off.
And by the coloration on the side,
I really thought for sure it was a gris,
um,
because I've seen lots of them and we
got up there and sure enough it was,
it was buried.
So we kind of took a lot of precaution
as we were trying to tell people just to
explain to people what that means.
So it Grizzly,
um,
they will bury something that they find
and they,
I think they do it for a couple reasons.
One of the reasons is they want,
they don't want like prey birds like
crows and stuff to be able to see it
because they'll start talking.
And then other predators in the area
listen for those birds and then,
you know,
it's kind of a magnet starts to draw,
so they like to conceal it.
So the literally kind of pivot on a
circle around that kill and actually
claw the ground in and bury them.
And it's like,
I've seen a were grizzlies barrier full
moose and it's,
it is ridiculous.
The type of dirt they can move,
I'm talking,
it looks like a skid loader came in
there and buried these things and they
can do,
they can do that kind of work fairly
quick.
Um,
but they'll pile up everything around it
and then they kind of normally we'll
create one small little hole at the end
of that mound where they'll kinda crawl
in there and they literally like eat
from one side to the other side,
you know.
And uh,
and it's normally the back end first.
Um,
so yeah,
I felt like we had just got there when
this bear had just discovered the
carcass and had just started the burial
process because he hadn't pulled
anything out of the trees.
He had only started to cover the
carcass,
which normally they'll cover that seal
first,
then they'll clean up the scraps around
and then they go to their pile and kind
of consume that last.
Um,
but I was certain that we had seen one.
We ended up seeing a wildlife biologist,
uh,
later on.
And I told him I thought I saw a grid
and he told me,
he said,
well,
it's pretty important if you did,
because there hasn't been one naturally
on this hill and I think he said a
hundred years.
So he's like,
you know,
would you be willing to go back in there
to put a camera up,
which is not smart.
If it was a,
if it was a Grizzly,
it's,
I mean,
obviously they're gonna be depending on
their demeanor.
They can be very protective of that.
Um,
but we did end up going back in there
just to put the camera up.
And then after the camera was there a
few weeks,
he sent a picture and said,
you were close to being right.
It's just a perfectly colored,
a black bear that looks like,
like it would be a grizzly,
but how does he know for sure?
You can tell by they don't have,
um,
you thought it was a grizzly when you
saw the photo?
Yeah.
They,
they don't have a very.
I thought it was a younger one,
but they don't have a very distinct,
um,
hump on their back.
And then the claw marks.
See he went in.
You can tell a lot by the clause.
So when you go in and you look at the
tracks,
that's also a really easy way because
like,
like that beer that was a wrestling
Khabib,
uh,
you could see the claws,
like grizzlies have very,
very distinct a clause.
So that was a just looking here.
So I can't really pull up the pick for
every sentence.
Jamie,
let me check it out.
Yeah,
I could see that.
That's Luke and that doesn't actually
kind of looked like a brown bear.
And now that I look at black bear
rather.
Yeah.
And then running the head is going to be
narrower and it took several pictures.
Some of the pictures that looked more
like a grid just because the coloration,
some of the pictures that didn't,
so,
um,
you know,
and keep in mind,
Mountain Grizzlies look a little bit
different than like a coastal bear or
inland grizzly,
but either way it was,
it was a bear that came in and covered
the whole carcass and went to eat it.
Now,
when you were in Alberta,
you went back to that place that you
were talking about on the first podcast
we ever did,
where you had that encounter,
where you shot that elk that was just
outside of that wolf den.
Yeah.
Wolves tried to claim the elk.
You guys how to shoot your way out of
there is a fucking crazy story.
What was it like to be back there again?
It was,
what was strange about it is while we
were there,
uh,
I actually found that they were back in
that area.
Um,
there was some fresh tracks and then we
heard one how like during that thing.
So it was almost like,
it was a little bit weird because I'm
just,
you guys bring extra bullets as time.
We only had my bow this time.
I'm sending you this Jamie.
Oh Jesus.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
the,
the thing that I'm,
the thing that was always kind of
creeped me out a little bit was just,
it was,
I felt like I had like a kind of a
personal connection with that Alpha male
because the way he came in at the very
end because he wanted to know what the
heck had taken out three of his pack.
He wanted,
like,
it's almost like he's like,
I know we're getting out of here,
but I want to see this for myself
because,
you know,
they were close enough but I don't think
they could totally see us.
So is that was going away.
Um,
grizzly.
Yeah.
It doesn't look like a brown or a black
bear though.
In the nose.
Yep.
See how the face is more narrow.
So yeah.
And then the cost to.
Yup.
Yeah.
Which,
like on the right foot,
the claw looks more like a black bear on
the left foot.
There was some grass there that made it
a little bit strange.
But um,
when that Alpha male came in to kind of,
you know,
I think he just wanted to know,
okay,
what's caused all this stuff?
So,
you know,
I looked at,
I looked him in the face and just pretty
much said I'm going to shoot you in the
face.
Um,
I always,
every time I go back in that area,
I'm like,
you know,
this old suckers walking around,
he knows my smell is going to be like
there's the members personally.
They are smart.
I could picture him remembering it and
saying,
oh,
okay,
this,
oh this,
oh,
this dude can make him into a hero
turret.
On the side of that,
I sent you that,
uh,
that Wolf Big Wolf Shit that had
porcupine quills,
all of that.
I put that on instagram.
It's funny how many people were like
that.
That is not porcupine quills.
It's like,
listen people,
I'm in the outdoors 200 days,
probably a year.
And if there's porcupine quills coming
out,
pile of Shit,
I'm pretty sure I know what it is.
It's hard to tell from a photo on my
instagram.
Here we go.
It's a pile of shit with porcupine
quills in it.
Imagine how God damn hungry.
You have to be to be eating porcupine.
Quills wolf's that tough.
He doesn't care.
It's like a bear.
Look at how many bears just.
We'll just go head first into a pile and
like a fire ant bed or a wasps' nests.
Like yellow jacket is.
Make that a little bigger please.
Down in the bottom you can see some nice
quills yeah,
yeah.
Some people will go to her.
The other is there is porcupine hair in
their.
Correct.
Those are all so close.
There's,
there's a couple of little blood drops
up there.
Need some prep age.
Um,
yeah,
they're,
they're beasts there.
Beast.
That is,
I think,
I think their intelligence,
their intelligence level is super high.
I think a lot of,
you know,
the more you're in the outdoors and you
experience things demeanors and their,
uh,
their ability to survive.
You know,
you look at,
uh,
one of the,
you look at an old grizzly that's been
in those woods for 20 years,
think of the experience level that thing
has surviving every single day.
I mean,
every day just maybe making a slight
mistake,
slipping up a little bit,
almost getting jacked by another
grizzly.
And then you're like,
oh,
Yep,
I know not to do this.
I know not to do that.
I mean they're there until their
intelligence level and their ability to
function is extremely high and wolves
are,
I mean arguably will probably get shot
less than probably any of the other
animals.
I mean,
they're in.
They are incredibly smart.
So yeah,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't doubt it,
you know,
it was,
I'm in there,
they,
they were very after that,
they were very intent in that area for
people to put up some pretty big
bounties on the wolves.
And they really went after him and,
and knock those herds down quite a bit
because there was very few mule deer,
like very few mule deer.
You'd hardly see a doe.
And,
and they had to cut the number of tags
way down a elk as soon as wolves.
Like how at night if a pack moves into
an area and they,
how like calling elk is just
nonexistent.
They just,
everything's just like don't say nothing
because you know,
they're here.
Um,
so yeah,
I think I think them thinning them down
was,
was very relevant.
And since then,
which was quite awhile ago,
um,
the numbers of like elk and Moose,
I like this past year I saw way more
moose than I've seen.
Um,
I think they're really hard on moose
fonds.
Um,
and yeah,
I mean Moose Mulally's white tails.
I saw way more animals this year,
uh,
than in the past up there.
And I think it's just because that Moose
number or the wolf number was just much
lower.
But there was,
like I said,
there was still sign that there was some
in the area,
just nothing.
Like several years ago when I was there,
it was,
you know,
it was even,
I would say,
as much as I appreciate balance in
nature,
it was excessive and it's getting that
way now.
Like even in Wisconsin,
I remember I was talking to a friend of
mine up in an area I used to live up by
kind of in the Lacrosse area,
actually lived a little northeast of
Lacrosse by a small town called
cataract.
And there was a few times where there
were some wolf spottings.
Um,
there's a big military base called Fort
Mccoy and I lived up on the northern
side of the base,
um,
what was called the impact area.
They kind of shot test rounds over and
they kind of went off there or whatever,
but there was an incredible number of
like deer
and things that were in there.
So,
you know,
kind of the rumor was that they had
introduced wolves into their timber
wolves to let,
to Kinda thinned down some of those
numbers will now it's to the point where
the amount of people I know in Wisconsin
that sea wolves is just rapidly
increasing.
And obviously when that happens,
you know,
they eat stuff.
I mean,
wolves don't mess around.
They take stuff down and sometimes it's
just strange.
You don't understand the balance of,
um,
of why there's an introduction to
something that you know,
has the possibility to just take over,
you know,
it's,
it's strange.
Well,
it is,
but it's also,
there needs to be some sort of balance.
You don't want the animals
overpopulating and you do want some sort
of a balance between Predator and prey.
But the real problem becomes when people
don't want to manage the predators,
right?
They only want,
they want nature to sort itself out.
Yeah.
It doesn't really work that way though.
I mean it's just people need to
understand like if you do like deer and
Moose and you,
like all these other animals,
you can't have too many wolves.
Too many.
Yeah.
You can't have too many grizzlies
because if you do,
you're going to have very few of those
other animals.
You're not gonna see them,
they're going to get wiped out.
And in some places like they're almost
at the point of extinction.
Like what,
what does that Caribou herd that's in
North America?
Caribou herd.
Yeah.
I'm not that familiar with it because
I've never really been a,
um,
a Caribou person,
you know,
from a hunting aspect,
but they're an animal that's like
severely targeted by wolves.
You.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I could see it.
Anything with a very predictable
migration is going to be very prone to,
you know,
to any type of prey creature you look
at,
you look at any of the migrations of
like willdabeast and stuff like that in
Africa where they're having to migrate.
Those crocs are just like,
oh yeah,
here we go.
We know where that river crossing is.
We know where the neck down.
It's the same thing.
It's terrible.
You know,
I mean,
I'm sure you knew this,
but many people don't.
The females actually have antlers and
the reason why they have antlers is to
fend off wolves.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
Female Caribou have antlers.
And one of the only deer species where
the females have antlers.
Yeah.
I didn't know he made sure that's true.
I don't think.
Well,
I mean,
I guess I guess if it's for wolves,
but they all have antlers,
right?
Fall Caribou,
have antlers.
Well,
you're male and flushing it.
I didn't think so,
but I think they do.
How good was a.
How good was that elk from that camp.
Oh,
fantastic.
Is that true?
I'm right.
You're usually right.
People would disagree.
I'd say eight times this.
A few times where I say things though,
when I go,
who the fuck are you saying?
You know what you're saying?
At least you a question.
Yeah.
You questioned it always,
and you laugh about it.
Now I'm no expert.
I'm an expert in very,
very few things.
But uh,
I think you have very,
uh,
your intelligence levels high.
It just says that males are,
tend to be a little bit bigger.
Antlers are a little bit bigger,
but yeah,
they both have.
Um,
yeah.
Well,
um,
see if it's true that the females have
it defend off wolves.
I think that's theoretical actually.
Anyway,
that's the part that,
that's the part where I was like,
well,
I'm pretty sure I saw that in a
documentary that the females have it to
fend off wolves.
That was speculation.
Speculation.
Three 60 video of what a cool animal
man.
They're so cool looking.
I've never hunted them.
I would like to.
They're supposed to be delicious and
there's a shitload of them.
Like that's the crazy thing about
Alaska.
The areas of Alaska,
like they'll have hundreds and hundreds
of them and these streams,
you know more than that depending on the
migration.
Yeah,
sure.
But I'm not streamed,
you know,
whatever path full of them.
There's one with no antlers.
Must have lost them.
Do they lose their antlers to them?
Have them.
It says there are exceptions.
Like there's this one dude got jacked,
but you see elk like that.
Yeah.
We see that I'm years had a broken time.
Didn't a little one.
Yeah.
Not,
not a big broken one,
but we saw one that I almost shot that
it only had one antler.
Yeah,
you'd like that were with me and you
shut that one white tail.
I'm like,
he's broken on one side you're like,
I want a gangster.
They're going down.
It doesn't bother me.
It the antlers to me,
a secondary.
Number one,
I want the meat and I want.
I'm a mature animal,
but to.
It doesn't bother me.
If there are things snapped off,
it means they're just going to war.
I was,
I was really pumped for that camp
specifically because I had several good
friends there and I really,
you know,
I'm just geeking out right now about
cooking,
you know,
I mean cooking stuff,
doing stuff different.
Um,
that neck that you made.
Exactly.
Oh my God.
I have to figure out.
You got to give me that recipe and I got
to figure out how to do that.
That was sensational,
man.
That was so good.
Grossed.
Yeah.
We had 51.
People will,
there's a lot of camera people there.
There was guides,
there was,
I think people that maybe worked there.
But yeah,
I made a,
a massive.
I took the one half of the elk neck and
did a forward seer.
So we've talked about reverse sear that
our buddy Chad ward taught us.
Um,
but this was a,
I call it affords here.
Maybe I'm wrong,
but it's just a car.
Yeah.
So I see her at the beginning,
uh,
in a big cast iron pot way to massive
cast iron pot barely didn't even fit in
the trigger.
Um,
and so we seared that whole neck and
then season it really well I season it
with like a,
a trigger prime rib rub and then a
coffee rub and then I put some of the
rifle and knocked and loaded coffee in
there and then put in.
I think about it,
it was the pot was so massive,
but I put in about six cups of bone
broth and then covered it with a cast
iron lid,
a wrapped it all up in foil and then
cooked it at 2:25
I think for about 18 hours because of
how big it was.
And then we knew it was about ready to
be done.
So we grilled some peppers and think is
that all we put in their grilled a bunch
of peppers and stuff was like bell
peppers,
Bell Peppers,
and I'm normally I'd do some Jalapenos
too.
We didn't have any.
And then onions in there too,
I feel like.
Yeah,
maybe some carrots or something in there
too.
Well there was,
there was onions.
We did grill some onions.
I'm kind of until they become allies,
but then open that up and more or less
just took two forks and it just fell
apart.
I mean just fell apart and kind of did
it all.
It looked like a looked like a pulled
pork butt is what it looked like.
And then we went ahead and put in all
the,
the grilled peppers and stuff in there,
put a little bit of sauce in there,
some Texas spicy and a little bit of
Saracha covered it back up and just let
it.
We actually took it out and set it in
the Yeti and then let it just kind of
sit in that Yeti for about what we went
out on the evening hunt and then we came
back,
um,
and then we ate it for dinner so it just
sat in that Yeti and just kinda maintain
temperature and just let all the juices
and everything re redistribute back
through that shredded meat after we
shredded it.
And then people just went crazy.
The amount of people that were coming up
to me saying,
what was that?
And I'm like,
neck.
And they couldn't believe it.
They couldn't believe that a giant bowl
with this neck that practically doubled
knives trying to cut through was just
that awesome,
but it really is like low and slow is
the name of the game on some of that
stuff and
well the those traeger grills,
any sort of pellet grill is such a great
way to cook something like that too
because you can maintain the exact
temperature for long periods of time.
And the thing about,
if you've never used a pellet grill
folks,
they use these pellets that are made out
of wood.
So like this table,
if you're going to make this table,
they would use a saw to make the table
and they would take the actual sawdust
and compress it and the natural sugars
in the would make this a compressed
pellet so they don't add any chemicals
or anything.
It's just wood.
And then they have this element that
heats it up and then they have this
little worm drive that feeds pellets
down into the heated up areas.
So the heated up area turns into the.
I look at that,
Bam,
the heated up area turns into fire and
you,
you got this little fire going on in
this hopper with this hopper feeds down
into this cup rather.
So the fires in the competent keeps
pellets in there,
so it's a natural fire,
it's just fire in wood and it gives us
great flavor to the food that you're
cooking.
Whatever we cook and vegetables or
anything,
you're cooking meat and in those things
maintain temperature so well,
so you could keep it on a 190 degrees
and just keep it at one 94 a fucking day
and they're so efficient that you never
have to add pellets.
A,
you could do the entire 16,
18 hours.
Where the cooking just on one hopper
full of pellets.
Oh,
easy.
Easy.
I think they said I think one bag of
pellets is equivalent to like a full
propane thing.
Yeah.
So this is what we cooked and Camp John
made a.
That is what's called the backstrap,
which is,
uh,
would be uh,
essentially a tomahawk cut.
Yeah.
It was a full of a full section of
Tomahawk steaks.
Those are all elk.
There's a pot in the back,
so it's basically the rib and where the
rib goes up to the top of the back and
the back that meet that goes along the
top of the spine is what most people
like best at Elc.
Yeah.
You gotta find that picture of.
So he cooked it like that with um,
with the bones attached just for
novelty,
but it was super delicious.
People like having that handled the chow
down on it was super delicious and the
fact that we were doing in camp from an
elk that you had shot literally the day
before it was as fresh as it gets.
Yeah.
And then you do an n in the mountains,
the view out there and just
incredible.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
It was,
I was happy to,
to tag out early just because of the
fact I was at know.
I had a lot of good friends there and we
were able to,
to grill out and chill out and,
and I think we probably ate about a
third of that thing over it a lot.
But yeah,
we ate a ton of it.
We ate a ton of it.
Which when you were in Alberta,
you shot a deer early in your hunt.
Didn't you guys eat the.
Almost the entire dear,
dear.
Yeah,
we did.
That's a big ass dear to.
Yeah,
we ate a ton of,
uh,
Andy's elk too.
When Andy Shadows bull on nine slash 11.
We still had I think five days left of
hunting,
so we ate elk three meals a day.
I'm.
One of the things I always do is I'll
always take a trigger with me or,
or um,
you know,
honestly it sounds weird,
but it's an investment to even if it's
one of the portable ones,
just to get one there to that new one
that they have is awesome.
The ranger,
really small one.
Yep.
That thing is perfect.
Yeah.
And it's not heavy either.
No,
that is the perfect size for,
for camping.
Yeah.
It's,
I'm trying to think.
I don't know what the weight is,
but yeah,
it's perfect for camping and you can
just plug it in.
Like I have a ram truck and you can
actually just plug in right inside.
I normally just have an extension cord
and run it through the rear window and
just plug and go.
I mean I took one with me and Sharon
went down to Oklahoma hunting and
actually a thing right there.
Yup.
Yeah.
How much does that thing,
where does it say?
I don't know.
It's not super late because I mean they,
they're,
they are heavy.
They are heavy duty.
Forty one pounds.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
I mean it's for,
on the go.
It's awesome.
In the new ranger,
one's actually a little better than that
one.
It's got a digital.
It's got a digital scale for the
thermostat is a new one for sale.
Yeah.
Whereas this one sold out.
Sold out there was the new one's called
the ranger.
Um,
but yeah,
they're,
they're dynamite.
You can just plug them in.
You don't.
Well we were talking.
Yeah,
there it is right there.
Three 99.
Yeah,
that's the thing,
you know,
if you lived in the city,
like I forgot to bring them up a lot
just because I think what he does is
cool.
But um,
I've got a buddy that lives in New York
and I found them on instagram working
out in central park all the time.
And uh,
one time I was in,
I was close to central park in the
morning and I knew he always worked out
early,
so I texted him like five in the
morning.
I said,
hey dude said,
are you up?
And you text back and said,
yeah,
his name is Joseph.
And I said,
I want to do one of these central park
workouts with you.
Any just carries some supplies and a big
backpack.
And he rux in and then he literally just
like has certain rocks and stuff and he
has a.
If he got there and you were on his
rock,
will you get mad?
No,
he would be happy.
See if you got to learn a lesson here by
Joseph.
Um,
yeah,
exactly.
So I did a workout with them,
but you know,
he was telling me he's like,
you know,
if you ever get any of that elk meat or
anything I'd love,
I'd love to try it.
And he's big into I think Quito.
Uh,
but he was telling me how much he pays
for store bought meat in New York and
I'm like,
oh my goodness,
that is astronomical.
And he's like,
and I don't really know where it comes
from,
you know?
And for someone that's,
that in tune with his body,
he was kind of disappointed that that's
what his options were.
But then I started thinking,
I'm like,
well,
do you have,
do you have the ability for like a
grill,
you know,
living in Iowa or live in where you
know,
you are.
We've got some,
some big grills.
We have the space for it,
but some people are thinking back to
myself when I was in my twenties living
in an apartment,
I wouldn't have had the space for that.
That right there is a great,
great option.
You know,
it's literally not much bigger.
And a couple of briefcases,
put it on your patio,
put it on your patio.
If you're cooking for two,
it would be perfect and you can easily
cook for two on that thing.
You can cook for more than two on that
thing in the cleanup is the most
important thing with any pellet grill.
If anyone's ever going to get one.
The two things I can tell you our most
important is one,
just recognize that you know,
it runs off a wooden pellet.
So treat pellet,
treat the like you would,
campfire would,
you know,
if you're,
if you leave camp firewood out where
it's getting rained on all the time,
you know it's going to be a pain to
start it or it's not going to burn that.
Great.
So if you keep those dry,
I always put my pellets after I pour the
bag in,
whatever's left,
I actually put in one of my Yeti buckets
and put that,
you know,
that kind of.
It's,
I dunno,
it's like a sealable lid that I pushed
down.
Um,
trigger makes buckets.
They're made specifically for them.
They sent me a couple of the buckets are
good,
but keeping your Palette,
you know,
if you're in a high humidity place like
Florida,
you don't keep,
don't keep your pellets outside.
Um,
you know,
if they're in the grill and you're using
the grill,
that's one thing,
but don't keep the bags out there all
the time.
And then as you use it,
there's the little,
it's called a,
I think they call it a burning pot.
Essentially your pellets are burning in
a small pot.
Uh,
think of that just the same as you would
a campfire pit as you're burning wood
all the time.
There's going to be ash left in.
If that pot fills up with ash,
there's not going to be the ability for
as much pellets to go in there so it's
not going to burn as hot.
So,
you know,
if you get to the point where you're not
able to get to your higher temperatures,
it's probably because you have too much
as you've got too much ash in your pot.
So yeah,
clean it out and then,
you know,
pretty much from there.
And be easy,
as easy as flipping it to on and turn it
to the,
to the template.
Sure.
That you want.
And it's done.
Yeah.
I was telling you that I tried cooking
on a regular grill,
a propane grill the other day,
and it just sucked.
It was flaring up.
There's a fire and smoke because the fat
was dripping down into the fire.
It's a shitty way of cooking.
They do have a really cool grill though.
The cooks from above.
I've seen one of those.
It's pretty bad ass.
Like you,
you,
uh,
you can raise or lower the heat and
bring it closer to the meat or lifted
above.
And so you don't get any flare ups.
Just cooks from above.
Well,
it's definitely a better way to do it if
you're using propane because that I
remember,
I remember once I bought some,
some rib eyes and this was back when I
didn't have the money to buy good
steaks,
but I had some people who are and I
thought I'm going to buy some good
steaks.
Went out and spent quite a bit getting
some good rib eyes and everything.
And because there's so much marbling,
I remember I came inside,
I had those on the grill,
it didn't even have them that high for
temperature.
I came inside and I started working on
vegetables are pouring drinks for people
and all of a sudden I look out and
there's just smoke rolling out of my
Weber and I go out there and lift it up
and I revise all that marbling.
Just,
it was just a big burning mess.
It looked like I took a flame thrower to
one half of my rib eyes.
So bummed out.
Yeah.
It's hard doing it right.
That's,
there's an art to cooking.
There is one of the things that I'm
really a learning from getting into
hunting and getting into cooking my own
food is learning how to do it correctly.
And it's fun.
There's a real art it,
you know,
like think that net gross that you made
or like some of the more interesting
things.
Do you ever do shanks?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I did.
Um,
I did two last week.
I shot that white tail in South Dakota
and I took both of the front quarters
and then did slow cooks with those in
there.
They're awesome.
You know,
the,
the key for any of that stuff that
normally has a lot of tendons and stuff
that's a tougher section of the meat.
A lot of people try to cook them too
fast and you don't break down that
Cartlidge,
you know,
you need that cartilage to really cook
slow to the point where like gels and it
breaks down and it almost turns into
marbling in it.
Then it'll turn into flavoring,
which is kind of what happened with
that,
with the neck,
you know,
once it cooks slow enough,
even all those harder tendons that are
in there,
they just slowly start decomposing them,
become more of a marbling that's mixed
in.
And it's really,
really good.
I mean it's,
it's awesome.
And I'm,
I'm a big advocate on the simpler you
keep things cooking wise for me,
the better the flavors are that I get.
I'm a very simple cook and when people
asked me to do,
you know,
people see pictures that I post cooking
and they're like,
well,
you know,
you need to do a cookbook.
No,
I'm not.
My cookbook would be boring because it
would be,
you know,
olive oil probably,
I would have coffee for rub and have
like a prime rib rub,
you know,
probably a decent like rock salt.
But other than that,
like grass fed butters,
olive oils or a couple basic rubs,
that's all I use period in a bone broth
if I do like a.
If I cook something slow to break down,
but I just literally stay with those
staple things.
And from there,
you know,
I'll cook according to the directions.
One of the things I learned to do was,
was rest my meat so I won't take meat
off and just cut right into it.
And you rested in a cooler?
Yeah,
I read it.
And a Yeti all the time.
All the time.
Cover it with aluminum foil and the
butcher paper.
Either when you do it,
like do you get it to a certain
temperature?
Really?
Say if you want your meat to hit an
internal temperature,
like 1:30,
do you get it to like 1:20
and then put it in the core and then let
it rise to like 1:30
while it's in there because it keeps
cooking.
Right.
Because it's gonna.
It's gonna rise.
Some it will rise.
Um,
you got to plan that out before you
arrested too.
If you're going to do it in a cooler,
right?
Yeah.
Normally I do.
It depends how long you're going to rest
it.
Normally I plan on about six degrees.
It'll go up.
But you can,
as you're resting in the cooler,
you can still check it,
you know,
you can let it sit for 10 or 15 minutes
and then check it.
Normally for me,
five degrees is a really good number.
Like if I'll stop five degrees less than
where
eat it because when I put it in there
and wrap it up,
most vegetables for me take 20 minutes.
Like as soon as I pull that off my
trigger,
I'll turn it up to high and then take
vegetables.
I just like tossed in olive oil and I'll
season them with a basic rub,
put them in there,
but anything like Broccoli,
asparagus,
peppers,
cauliflower,
anything like that that I cook on there
isn't going to take 20 minutes roughly
on high and the meat is just resting at
that point.
And then I can literally pull the meat
off if I want to do reverse sear,
I can do it just long enough to where
that temperature hits the exact number
if it hadn't reached that yet.
Um,
otherwise I can just slice it and
according to,
you know,
the color throughout that I'll serve it
out to everybody according to whether
they want something a little more done.
You give them.
One of the NPS is if people want it less
done,
you give them the peace in the middle.
Um,
but typically if I'm going to let it
rest for 20 minutes,
I'll pull it about 129 degrees because I
like mine at like 1:35
or so you like,
here's a little less.
You like yours?
A little redder than me.
I think he like yours that more like
1:30
finished don't yet.
That's the other thing too is besides
keeping,
you know,
the basics for seasoning is those
thermopolis right?
I mean if you have a probe,
that's the one thing that I learned from
our buddy Chad Ward is,
you know,
when he travels,
he travels with a good knife and he
travels with a probe and minds from
thermo works,
um,
is one I got as a gift someone gave me
and I can tell you that that was one of
the best things to get.
I have a regular internal thermometer
that's really cool because I can keep it
in the kitchen and it's got a one probe
and then the,
uh,
it registers to a second unit which you
can keep as a remote.
You keep it far,
far away from the grill.
It tells you what's going on.
It's like Bluetooth or something or
wireless.
Yup.
I'm Steve Rinella.
Actually has a really good cook book
that just came out.
I should say that I was going to have it
in here today.
Uh,
he sent it to my house and it's at my
house right now,
but yeah,
literally just came out his own Ninja
Ninja level.
Yeah.
If you want to take things to the next
level.
I mean he is,
uh,
he's,
he's one of those rare guys that has a
television show,
a hunting television show.
We're literally,
most of the episodes is cooking
something.
That's it right now.
Mediator fishing game cookbook.
Okay.
It's available November 20th.
It's not available to you.
Fucks yet.
I already have it.
Sorry folks.
But uh,
it's really good though.
It's excellent.
He sent me a publisher's version that
had like just black and white photos,
but I just got the full version a couple
of days ago and it's really excellent
and,
but he's got really,
really cool recipes and interesting
stuff.
And,
and if you don't have any wild game
meat,
you could always buy bison from
supermarkets.
Some supermarkets have that and you
could cook that and cook it in the same.
We're going to bust advice and this
winter.
Yeah,
for a good cause to come in and a
fucking bice and
code ons on.
I want to do all my podcasts.
That giant Bison coat better get an air
conditioner.
This sucker dude.
I love Bison.
Yeah,
it's delicious.
It is,
it is awesome.
It is awesome.
Yeah.
Um,
you,
myself and our buddy andy stump,
we're going to go,
uh,
for sure.
Me and Andy,
both of our bison are going to be for
that meat is going to have a purpose.
I'm andy and I kinda,
I don't know,
through,
through some just talk at a hunting
camp.
Kind of started this thing that we call
free range American.
Right?
And it's,
it's literally brand that's not really
about us.
It's just about all of these we have,
we have all these friends that just do
crazy stuff.
And Andy's arguably one of the craziest
friends.
I got crazy.
Yeah.
He's probably the craziest holds the
world record for the furthest distance
travel.
When those flying squirrel suit,
he's out of his fucking mind.
He is the craziest,
but we just,
one time we were just talking about um,
you know,
just awesome shit people do and he's
like,
you know,
we need to just,
we just need to motivate people.
And,
and just talk people into tagging us
when they do awesome shit.
And so then,
uh,
sure.
Yeah,
the shirt you're wearing.
Yeah.
And did you guys start this company
together as teacher company?
Yeah.
Well it's more than just that,
but yeah,
the entire brand or you know,
like the social media stuff is all just,
it's based around people that,
you know,
just tag us with the Hashtag,
do awesome shit.
And they show us what they're doing is
free ranging Americans and you know,
it's anything,
it's not just what Andy and I like.
I mean if we,
you know,
we uh,
some guys are firemen that just do crazy
stuff.
There's people that have some,
you know,
there's been some motor,
some imacs,
guys that just post some crazy ass
pictures like Shane Dorian,
some of the waves he's on,
that's just crazy shit that he's,
what are you going to do with the meat
from the license?
We're gonna.
Um,
Andy's got a big,
uh,
a big fifth wheel calls it,
the do awesome shit.
Immobile.
And we're going to pull that from.
We're going to start on the west coast,
um,
this spring and we're going to start,
were andy went through buds and we're
going to hit a base for one of each of
the military branches.
We're going to try to end at Fort Bragg
where I was born.
Um,
but we're going to start with a navy.
We're going to end with a,
with the army and we're going to go to
basis and we're just gonna Cook wild
game out on the doodle.
Do Awesome Shit.
Mobile.
We've got triggers.
I'm Chad Ward's going to be following
close behind with some giant rolling
triggers and we're gonna we're gonna.
Get these bisons ground up to do some,
uh,
some cool bison burgers and stuff like
that and just hit a bunch of military
bases.
You're going to need a lot.
We're gonna.
Take some buffaloes down and then we're
gonna we're going to also have some
really cool brands,
uh,
supporting us.
But yeah,
we're more or less just trying to
support the troops,
um,
promote,
you know,
clean eating,
doing awesome shit.
And um,
it's going to be fun.
So we're still working out the details,
but that's going to be coming and uh,
I'm super thankful all my,
all my friends that are,
that are military base or have served
for us and,
and uh,
you know,
it's just another way that I can do one
of the few things I'm good at.
I can show people how to shoot archery
or I can cook for them.
That's kind of my forte.
And uh,
yeah,
I'm looking forward to it.
I think it's going to be.
I think it's going to be a mobile party.
That sounds fun.
Giving them down.
I'll,
I'll let people know.
I'll put it on social media and we'll
talk about it here and let folks know a
John Kavanagh should be here any second
now if he's not already here,
I don't know if they're here yet or they
hit someone's here.
They're here.
Okay.
So we're going to talk to conor
Mcgregor's coach and George Lockhart,
who's Connor's a,
um,
weight cutting coach.
And I think he does his nutrition as
well.
Looked at and talked to him,
did look dynamite while he's getting
fucked up.
Pretty good to fucking hard sport.
It's a hard sport,
you know,
he,
I'll tell you one thing though.
He is,
it would have been nice to talk to him
afterwards because I think he would have
been gracious in defeat.
I really do.
Yeah,
I agree with ast.
I agree.
I think he was on social media,
you know,
he said it was a good crack,
uh,
I mean maybe we'll get a rematch,
you know,
he talked to tremendous amount of shit
and it's just hard for people to recover
from that.
But part of the game,
part of the fun part of it.
John Dudley.
Alright.
A knock on TV.
You can catch him on instagram and you
could.
No,
no.
Kay on the front end.
O C K TV archery.
Knock in.
And if you're interested in archery,
that's to follow the free range.
American.us.
There you go.
Alright fuckers.
See you soon.